hello and welcome to video playing me
high-low 95 which is a new opponent
haven't played him before vinegar right
so our that's an audible water so I have
that you have a choice now between being
better in various ways and I'd c3 is an
advantage C for everything basically
okay let's play an open Sicilian where
the knight is committed on to the seven
prematurely what are you doing there
can't even take him
it looks difficult for black already
hmm it cannot really take only five and
what are you playing if I can take on
these six and give black that week d6
pawn it's also not very nice
and it seems like relatively a
relatively good choice
okay Knight b5 a relatively good means
black is still in pretty awful shape but
we have to move just nothing good
available
now you can just take this 6cm one there
anything better
even you can take here
yeah Queen Queen d6 is also possible I
just wonder what the best way is to to
play click with the Queen it's tough the
same just back to c4 Bishop e3 will be a
huge temple ok gives me the bishop a as
well it's nice
yeah I mean probably it didn't make a
huge difference but Bishop takes f3 is
it helpful
okay so 95 and c4 hmm
now it's probably okay to support the
night
yeah and one day I'm just Bishop III on
a kinky one is also not bad it's just
play King d1 I didn't really want him to
take on b2 even though it's off was
probably not very dangerous in the first
place
yeah there's no good move just no good
move available um yeah just king c2 arm
what am I going to do
rookie one
hmm yeah
not super happy with this move but i
have to play something yeah no he cannot
take on veto after rupee one that's not
going to be we cannot survive that
mmm oh is there something better let's
think about it for a moment it really
looks like it should be over immediately
also play we should take some but yeah
this is threatening to take on c5 take
on b5 don't think there's a reply really
you know the other did that opening is
just gonna play like that
1997 I went 90 have three because I was
hoping for a transposition to a fitty
door which is very nice
you played c5 rather after which you
have a wide choice of good lines
I went Knight c3 and now I should
probably take on d4 it is not a good
Sicilian but it's relatively best when
g6 is just not right I think Bishop c4
is even stronger because I'm threatening
to take on f7 but okay this is a simple
way to continue taking here it looks
terrible and black black has no
development and I play Queen d2 long
castles and that's bad
five black now has no good way of
avoiding structural weaknesses it's just
impossible yeah I will take on d6 and
kill blacks pawn structure the end you
have to Knight b5 not b5 isn't even
mentioned by the engine I mean it's
clear that the other moves are good but
okay Knight e4 was relatively best I
thought I just go here but that isn't
even so clear I should play Bishop f4
yeah that I probably wouldn't have
played that also means that probably
this is indeed stronger now I just win
d6 am working at a it has to be played
and that is really terrible
you played Bishop g4 and I just decided
to take the pawn
yeah I didn't quite know why you should
take on a three but it's kind of it's
probably a moot point is this position
you cannot save probably there should be
three is stronger yeah I kind of
suspected it but probably will do you
one yeah yeah who do you want I should
do that now came and one thing is like
here I can take twice this is what I did
not see at all I can win this the king
the one is lame in comparison really
really lame I'm still better but it's
not as much as it should be but I think
and yeah this is this is this is ending
the game basically I can take on c5 play
93 that said stronger but you're not
surviving that either it's too much 93
and so on can't hear black lose the size
material you know that it's not an
opening play that you can know that you
can survive very funny anemia the red
defense
until-- defense what is the internal
defense okay thanks for watching